Democrats still think they know what's
best when it comes to your kids
education a proposed bill in Georgia
wants to give parents more say in which
schools their kids go to but a Democrat
lawmaker says not so fast she thinks
some moms and dads are too stupid to
know what's best
a lot of those parents did not finish
High School I am extremely concerned
that we would put money in their hands
in that in that entire piece of life in
the hands of parents who are not
qualified to make those decisions and
they don't have the money to put in the
difference that their child would need
to attend a private school
you know that is so shocking it is so
disgusting I can't even I and I'm not
I'll ask what your opinion is on that
Brian well I'll tell you what I did we
played uh we played this this morning uh
on uh Fox and Friends and I couldn't
believe it look into her background she
feels as though if a parent doesn't have
a higher education they're not qualified
to uh qualify to pick the curriculum in
bright school for their kids so we'll do
it we care about your kids more than you
do which is a no-go Zone some of the
smartest people I know have the least
education uh so uh formal education
number two Arkansas Utah Iowa Arizona
they all have school choice I hope more
and more States follow that just empower
the families to make the choice and let
them make decisions for their kids
you're always better off you know Jesse
to me this seems like you know it's the
teachers union the public schools it's
all about the money and they're in it
together and you know the truth is that
those public schools are the ones that
are failing and this legislator has the
absolute nerve to say if you didn't grad
graduate from high school I mean some of
the smartest people I know didn't
graduate from high school and are making
millions and billions billions yes
who I'll tell you like so the way they
make uh money in in the state of Georgia
they take the total number of public
school students and then they take all
of the public school teachers and that's
how they determine teacher sellers so if
more poor kids get these vouchers to go
to Charter Schools that's less amount of
total public school students that's
their salaries go lower that's what this
is about okay Dana well when I the first
thing I thought of when I heard this was
I do believe that every parent wants the
very best for their children and I
thought about Senator Tim Scott so he
writes in his book about his grandfather
who did not right but high school and
one of the things you used to do is he
would make sure his kids did the
homework and then he would sit there
with the newspaper and he would hold it
at the kitchen table and he would look
at he would just be looking at the
newspaper he couldn't read
and he and his grandson became a U.S
senator so I think that there's not a
better animating force in politics right
now than children's education and
parental rights and you just look in
Virginia governor Glenn Younkin won that
race largely on that issue it wasn't
about a political curriculum it was
about parental Choice and then there's a
group called
um I'm sorry I wrote it down right here
parents defending education in every one
of their polls they have
71 percent of Voters opposing for
example withholding information about a
child's gender from the parents 75
percent want schools to require teachers
or staff to inform parents if their
child wants to change their names and
pronouns that's the kind of thing that
parents want control over and they want
the best for their children so I I
understand I also don't think that I
don't want to impugn the motives of the
of the legislator I assume that she also
wants the best for her children and for
the children of her State I just think
she's wrong well the irony the irony of
this Jessica is that she sent her own
kids to private school and yet she
deigns to speak on behalf of parents who
you know have their kids in public I
mean 78 got to read the package 78
percent of the kids in those Atlanta
schools tested below the proficiency
level for math so maybe the teachers
ought to focus on being better teachers
I think the fact actually that her kids
went to private school backs up her
perspective on this she was an educator
for 30 years she served on ptas school
boards worked in classrooms and her
argument is that you give money to
people where the parents are going to be
paying attention to make sure that
they're on top of all of these things so
I don't think there's an inconsistency
there I do think and you're right to
bring up what Terry McAuliffe said
um in the race in Virginia where he said
like teachers are the ones who should be
in charge of your kids like these are
sound bites of death for Democrats right
you run those during the campaigns and
it's going to be a tremendous problem
and I do think going out coming out of
the pandemic where so many people had
terrible educational outcomes and had to
turn to pod learning homeschooling uh
you know millions of kids different from
the public school system that it is
going to be on Democrats to have to make
a very clear and potent case for why
there shouldn't be a voucher system for
five six thousand dollars I'm not saying
that you know every kid gets a free ride
to the top private schools in the
country but when the public school
system did fail so many and if you are
going to continue to advocate for that
and I think a strong I think we all
would agree that a strong Public School
System makes for the country better
but you're going to have to show up and
defend that if vouchers are going to be
available to people why they should stay
in the public schools yep absolutely hi
winner Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now